ministre François Braun a présenté
aujourd'hui ses vœux aux forces vives de
la santé c'est ce qui nous intéresse
alors pas de grande annonce mais pour
autant a-t-il convaincu donner de
l'espoir ou redonner de l'espoir aux
professionnels on va leur poser la
question justement André Grimaldi est
avec nous sur ce plateau bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes professeur et mérite
diabetologue au CHU de la
Pitié-Salpêtrière vous avez consigné une
tribune dans le journal Le Monde il y a
quelques jours et on aura l'occasion
d'en parler et vous avez aussi écrit le
livre l'hôpital nous a sauvé sauvons le
vous faites 10 propositions de mesures
pour sauver l'hôpital public c'est sorti
en novembre dernier Pierre schweppelier
est également avec nous bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes vous infirmier et
qu'au président du collectif
interurgence et on est également
connecté avec Philippe Vigier bienvenue
à vous député MoDem membres de la
commission des affaires sociales
messieurs sur ce point-là Philippe
Vigier vous représentez le modem
Philippe Vigier le MoDem qui est allié
de la majorité qu'est-ce que vous avez
envie de répondre à ce qui se dit sur ce
plateau
j'ai envie de vous dire deux choses la
première on a redécouvert l'hôpital avec
cette covid où on a vu le personnel
soignant première ligne qui a été
capable de renverser les montagnes dans
les conditions la seconde chose moi
c'est pas aujourd'hui que j'explique
l'hôpital va mal je suis désolé mais le
fait que tous les hôpitaux soient géré
uniquement par des administratifs et un
non sens absolu revenu à une
organisation complète hospitalière dans
laquelle dans la gouvernance les
personnels soignants seront représentés
avec l'administration de façon
fonctionnelle opérationnelle service par
service ça sera une avancée considérable
vous parliez à l'instant des infirmières
au sort Grimaldi a raison et il en fait
beaucoup plus mais je rappelle aussi que
il appartient par exemple au Conseil
régionaux dont la compétence leur
étonnée depuis 2004 de l'ensemble des
formations
sanitaires et sociales d'augmenter cette
formation dans ma région Centre-Val de
Loire on augmente la formation de 50% en
3 ans mais suffit pas d'en former faut
mieux les payer et actuellement s'il y
en a qui part c'est parce qu'ils ne sont
pas bien donc quand est-ce qu'on va
faire la carrière et avec une
valorisation je vais prendre un exemple
parce qu'il est dans toutes les têtes
c'est suivre ce qu'on appelle des IPA
c'est l'acronymes qui veut dire des
infirmières des pratiques avancées qui
pourraient jouer un rôle absolument
central dans la délégation de tâches
avec les médecins savez-vous qu'on lui a
une IPA est payée à l'hôpital par
rapport à une infirmière entre
guillemets classique 3 ans de formation
initiales à 5 ans elle est payée 50
euros de plus par mois c'est absolument
scandaleux donc voilà donc il faut
réouvrir cette organisation je crois
dans un pays dans lesquels on met
beaucoup d'argent sur la table
malheureusement il y a des déperditions
considérables je le regrette comme
d'organisation et cette tutelle
administrative de tout instant je la dis
dans mon département dans l'hôpital que
je connais bien à Châteaudun en
Eure-et-Loir à tout moment enfin
redonnons le pouvoir mais également donc
au personnel soignants mais également
les citoyens soient associés nettement
plus à la gestion de l'offre de soins et
la gestion hospitalière en particulier
alors moi je vais vous dire ça fait de
longues années que qu'on donne le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital mais on ne
peut pas parler que de l'hôpital pour
parler également de la médecine de ville
parce que l'un et l'autre doivent
fonctionner ensemble et il y a trop de
cloisonnement et d'ailleurs lorsqu'on
voit ce qui se passe dans les urgences
c'est parce que la médecine de ville
malheureusement on n'arrive plus à
fournir parce que tout ça ça vient de
très loin c'est parfaitement lorsqu'on a
mis en place le numéro closus alors on
commence à l'ouvrir et on l'a ouvert
depuis 2001 on a fait sauter ce mytosus
qui est devenu un numerus apertus comme
vous savez parce que le drame c'est
qu'il y a 67 millions de Français mais
il y a moins d'heures de temps médical
disponible qu'il n'y avait il y a 30 ans
ça personne n'en dit mot la deuxième
chose la tarification à l'activité c'est
une folie furieuse vous l'avez dit
vous-même et moi je suis d'accord avec
vous je vous rappelle que c'était mis en
place à la fin du quinquennat Nicolas
Sarkozy et que ça a connu son apogée
quand sous le quinquennat de Monsieur
Hollande avec Madame Touraine qui est
immense de la santé et par exemple vous
voyez les difficultés auxquelles les
assistons on essaie de faire un maillage
des professionnels de santé sur le
territoire ce qu'on appelle les
communautés territoriales des
professionnels de santé les médecins des
infirmières des kinés des pharmaciens
tous ceux qui savent de travailler
ensemble au quotidien avec une
délégation de tâches et ça c'est
indispensable de faire en sorte que l'on
redonne du temps disponible en déléguant
un certain nombre de tâches mais on a vu
combien c'était difficile des syndicats
de médecins ne sont pas tous favorables
c'est soit non programmé que nous
essayons de mettre en place dans de
faire en sorte que les médecins qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant puissent
en trouver un cela faire l'objet d'un
financement de la sécurité sociale mais
là le diable est en dans tous les
détails si tout le territoire d'un
département n'est pas couvert en soins
nos programmes et il n'y a pas de
financement de la Sécu donc on revient à
un sujet il faut mieux rémunérer les
médecins je dis très clairement il faut
aussi faire en sorte que toutes les
actions territoriales qui fonctionnent
moi je suis dans un grand désert médical
au fin fond de l'Eure-et-Loir et bien
croyez bien que les soins non programmés
ils fonctionnent et la moitié des
médecins ont intérêt à cette démarche il
y en a comme ça soulage un peu les
urgents de notre hôpital là il faut
réorganiser complètement cet hôpital je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure la gouvernance
et un élément absolument majeur enfin
peut-être un mot sur l'ONDAM j'ai
dénoncé le fait que l'on dame n'est pas
plus élevé pour 2023 mais reconnaissez
tous avec moi quand même qu'il y a eu un
effort particulier qui a été fait avec
les Ségur de reprise des hôpitaux parce
que on refuse on cache la poussière sous
le tapis quand on connaît le montant de
la dette des hôpitaux accumulés au fil
du temps mais ça de côté et bien ça
n'est pas acceptable il faut repartir
sur des basses saines ça prendra du
temps et nous nous disons en tout cas
démocrate distale assemblée il faut un
plan puret annuel je pense qu'il faut 5
ans pour reconstruire un hôpital qui
fonctionne bien avec une vocation
d'urgence immédiate pour que dans les
quelques mois qui sont devant nous tout
ce qui marche dans les territoires et
bien on soit capable de le porter un peu
au niveau national parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'initiatives beaucoup de
générosité beaucoup de créativité mais
en place par les professionnels de santé
à la colère et l'émotion aussi d'André
Grimaldi qu'on vient d'entendre à
l'instant
j'ai la même colère et je suis désolé je
suis pas dans une posture il a qu'à
regarder mes déclarations en 2018 je
disais Buzin qu'il fallait supprimer la
téléa et arrêter tout cela donc je suis
très très à l'aise pour répondre très à
l'aise elle l'a pas fait
du tout vous m'écoutez monsieur Grimaldi
elle l'a pas fait et ma voix n'a pas
suivi à emporter la vision mais voyez
depuis le début de propos je n'arrête
pas de vous dire faut démonter cela
deuxièmement sur la gouvernance
pardonnez-moi des chefs de service comme
vous mais sont toujours très demandeurs
j'en ai vu plusieurs pour une congestion
de l'hôpital et ras-le-bol de cette
gestion uniquement par les
administratifs et j'essaie de quoi je
parle les groupements hospitaliers de
territoire qui sont montés vous pouvez
pas me dire autre chose que c'est une
pompe aspirante pour tous les centres
hospitaliers qui en sont rattacs qui
sont rattachés donc qu'il faille bien
sûr faire un grand plan sur l'hôpital
oui qu'il fallait redonner les moyens
encore oui vous savez intervenir à
plusieurs reprises quel que soit les
présidents de la République moi j'ai eu
l'avantage d'être député c'est Nicolas
Sarkozy sur François Hollande
excusez-moi je me permets simplement de
vous couper qui nous reste peu de temps
j'aimerais juste savoir qu'est-ce qui
bloque du côté politique pour qu'on y
aille une fois pour tous pour aider
l'hôpital public et le système de santé
qu'est-ce qui fait que aucun président
ne mette réellement les mains dans le
cambouis écoutez au moins Emmanuel
Macron peut-être pas parfait il a mis
les moins dans le Cambri en décidant au
moins de 20 milliards on avait rien fait
sur les 15 dernières années en terme de
plan d'investissement je connais des
hôpitaux qui depuis 30 ans 40 ans n'ont
jamais fait l'objet d'investissement
absolument massif il y a une différence
majeure entre les CHU et les centres
hospitaliers généraux les chiro voyez je
me suis battu depuis 20 ans pour une
faculté de médecine à Orléans rendu
compte 20 ans de combat donc les
parlementaires on veut bien accepter de
prendre toutes nos responsabilités mais
à un moment madame pour vous répondre il
faut peut-être qu'on soit capable de
passer les clivages politiques voyez on
vient d'ailleurs de déposer une
proposition de loi transpartisone de
plusieurs groupes d'assemblée nationale
pour améliorer l'accès aux soins ces
sujets-là dépassent l'équipage politique
et enfin j'ai été surpris tout à l'heure
d'entendre dans la bouche du professeur
grimaldik le besoin de l'anglais Saxon
était mieux il y a vraiment en France
n'oublions pas de l'assurance maladie
elle est gratuite pour chacun je
l'invite et il le sait très bien il sait
comment ça se passe en Angleterre aux
États-Unis ou ailleurs vraiment là c'est
plutôt une médecine largement à deux
vitesses ou ceux qui ont les moyens de
se soigner se soignent alors ce sera
pour l'instant le mot de la fin mais
vous